the I like convenience so if I'm flying
somewhere I don't like to take three
stops to save money I like to just spend
the money on no stops one of the
resources that you cannot buy any more
of his time right how long is this
commute you talking maybe an hour a day
they're an hour a day back two hours a
day five days a week at the end of your
life you'd give you fortune for an extra
minute I think that's very important now
all that might change when there's
automated driving I think you'll see
kind of these mobile offices driving
around so you can live much further away
from your place of work I mean if you
think about it right now the equivalent
is taking a train into work within a
train you know it's a little crowded
you're sitting next to somebody you
don't really have like a desk but still
I've heard of people doing remarkable
things on their commute to work by
working on the Train right in one friend
of mine wrote the movie pitch perfect by
writing one page today on the subway I
into work when everything's automated
and convenient and quick people will
think about this in terms of lifestyle
like how can I live further away from
the city and get all the benefits of
being at work which is what automated
driving should give us
James hey Mon welcome the show Chris
thanks for having me on the show I'm so
glad to be here isn't it aren't intro so
awkward like you just know you know you
never really know what to say and how to
bring people in I always have a hard
time on podcasts with the intros is the
single worst bit of the job and I you
know behind the curtain I hate doing it
every single time do I do this weird
like foreplay fellatio thing where I'm
telling them about all their
accomplishments or the inside seam
measurement and what you worked what you
like to eat before you go to bed and
stuff like I don't know well you know
here's here's an idea I'm gonna try this
I'm gonna do an intro and then I'm gonna
just start talking to people we get into
conversation and then I'm gonna hit
record and this way it's like people
just jump right into the conversation do
you know who Rory Sutherland is uh yeah
I've heard the name I don't I don't know
who he is
vice chairman of Ogilvy advertising in
the UK you need okay to get him on let
me link you to up for your podcast man
because you absolutely excellent but
that that guy is the exact same as
trying to step onto a train that is
moving at high speed so podcasting with
him he just went so I was like right
Rory I'm just gonna I'm just gonna do a
little bit of a sound check and then
we'll do an intro and you went right
Russia and then just started talking
about Russia and I was like no Rory I
never mind just hit the record but knows
that right I'll just get cracking from
the beginning that's funny yeah that's a
good idea
I'm gonna try that too it's fun man
right so um where do we start
I tell you what why don't we start we
started something that would be a good
story for everyone so you've failed
quite spectacularly a couple of times
and then bounced back and then failed
again and bounced back can you take us
through some of those experiences and of
what they meant to you and what you
learn from them yeah I mean I think it's
always hard because I've told you know
I've written about this story and I
always try to have a new take on it but
the reality is I didn't I I always got
ahead of myself didn't know what I was
doing and then fail spectacularly so for
instance I built and sold a business
in the 90s I wasn't a businessman I
didn't want to be an entrepreneur at
zero interest I just kind of stumbled
into it sold the business made millions
and I thought I was smart like you think
when you were when you're smart in one
area you kind of think you're smart in
every other area so I started just I
know I had enough money for not only me
to survive a lifetime but my children's
children to survive a lifetime and two
years later I was so stupid during those
two years I had I had 140 I was left
with 143 dollars left in my bank account
total that was all I was worth I was
losing my house losing everything didn't
know what I was gonna do ad I had no
friends left because you know and this
was 20 years ago but you know basically
on the way up everyone wants to be a
friend and on the way down nobody knows
you and it wasn't because they were bad
or I was bad or I was good it's just you
know I didn't do the right things to
cultivate the best possible
relationships and I kind of thought the
money would always last and the money
would keep on flowing and I just didn't
realize that that for the first time in
my life bad things could could really
happen I was used to just starting from
zero having nothing it was better when I
had nothing that when I had Millions
because then I just started making
stupid decisions and started getting
really depressed about losing everything
and then by the time I had lost
everything
I was phenomenally depressed and so then
you know starting from scratch is hard
but I'll you know we could talk the
details but I basically this happened to
me several times like I would start
something new make a lot of money then
lose everything start something new make
a lot of money lose everything start
something new make a lot of money lose
everything it took me a long time to
realize you know what it's me
it's doing someone's denominator here
right they clear the total common
denominator was that I was an idiot and
there's three skills to money
there's making it keeping it growing it
and somehow I had the skill of making it
and which by the way I didn't know at
first yeah I had to learn that but then
I realized it took unfortunately I
learned realized too late
I had no skill at keeping it and growing
and I had to really start from scratch
learning those skills and that was that
was difficult you know now it's 20 years
later knock on wood I think I have those
skills well but we'll see maybe I'll go
abroad tomorrow we never know yeah I
suppose those strategic learning
experiences right like there's no bigger
way to deliver a hammer blow learning
than by going broke a couple of times
from a few million no I mean but the
thing is you don't you don't say to
yourself oh this is great I just lost
everything learning opportunity like it
just says visceral there right yeah it
just doesn't it just doesn't happen that
way like like I would lose everything
the very first time was probably the
hardest because I thought to myself you
know I just won the lottery
like basically like I didn't know
anything about business or
entrepreneurship I knew I knew how to
build a website in the 90s and no one
else did so I shouldn't say no one else
did but very few people did and I knew
how to I was like maybe one of the best
at doing it in terms of both technology
and understanding of you know what what
my client's needs were I was a good
salesperson I understood what their
needs were
I built a business and I built websites
for American Express comm all a lot of
record labels a lot of entertainment
companies are all sorts of big major
companies and we built it up we sold it
and a lot of my business and experience
took place during this process like I
could have been a software company
instead of a service company like I
could have I had software to help me
build websites but I didn't use it as
software I use it as services which I
didn't understand that software
companies are bought for higher
valuations than service companies so I
was valued on a multiple of my profit I
was a profitable Internet company which
was a horrible mistake during the 90s
and so I sold but I still sold for a
good
like my my friends were selling their
companies for like 300 million dollars I
sold mine made 15 million and then and
then I started and I and I cashed out it
wasn't like I had paper I cashed out I
was I thought to myself this internet
boom is not gonna last forever I was
smart and then even though I thought
that and even though I cashed out here's
what I did I invested all the money in
Internet companies and I just and then I
also bought like the biggest house I
could possibly buy and I would take you
know helicopters everywhere if I wanted
to go like down the street I would take
a helicopter like it was just no no
expense was was too big and I quite
correctly lost everything
and I thought to myself oh my gosh this
I had won the lottery I'm never gonna be
able to do this again I don't know what
I'm doing and I don't want to I don't
want to go back to what I was doing
before like what am I gonna do be like a
junior programmer at some accounting
firm not there's anything wrong with
that but I already had tasted you know
Mount Olympus yep and I wanted to I
didn't know what to do I was really
scared and unhappy and really scared and
like to the point of being suicidal like
I had when I was riding high I took out
a extensive life insurance policy for my
kids it might be my kids were still
babies I figure they're not gonna
remember me so I thought it would be
better for them to have the life
insurance policy than me and that's how
dark it was getting and you know and
then I was really unhappy I would say
for the next I don't know maybe ten or
eleven years as I just I was constantly
in the struggle to kind of succeed again
and every time I succeeded I would lose
it again I just I I didn't know what was
going on
disappointments suck and they yeah like
yeah it's a it's a really really
crucifying emotion to have to have
something that you thought was right or
good or there you had it and now you
don't have it and you got this sort of
wistful hole of where it used to be
yeah and and and I thought okay the way
I can make it back is through business
the business world but I was never a
business guy to being it nowhere and I
didn't really enjoy business and so I
kept staying focused on okay well I'll
just do this one more business and then
I'll get back to what I truly love which
is a really horrible attitude to have
like you know I basically spent
something like 25 percent of my life you
know in this pursuit of that Holy Grail
again being desperately unhappy and
stressed and anxious and you know it was
all the things that happened I can't
really remember that many pleasant
memories from promoters even people say
oh how about your kids nope because I
would hang out with my kids and I was
think man I just
I blew their future too I not only blew
my future I blew their future and and
every time I spent time with them I'd be
anxious about business so I even I I you
know people say oh I have no regrets
else I wouldn't be Who I am today which
is true but but I do regret not taking a
different kind of world view on what was
happening to me a bit different macro
view because I bet I bet you I could
have done many things and still done
well and I was just so focused on on
business and it was just such a stupid
thing to focus on well hindsight is
20/20 isn't it you've always has perfect
vision when you look backwards so one of
the things that I thought it was really
interesting was you don't have this like
Hollywood Joe Rogan's style like grit
your teeth and no dogs gonna guy I'm the
dog that if you kick me I get back up
and you know it's not that kind of like
really romantic level of resilience and
grit it it seems a lot more real than
that yeah like I don't think I had any
resilience and you know Joe Rogan I
don't know his full story I really
admire him I admire his podcast I admire
his interviewing style and his
background but he kind of went from to
his credit because I think he's a smart
guy
he went from success to success like he
was a struggling stand-up comedian but
it's not like he made it to the top and
fell and then he was a
various TV shows including Fear Factor
and and at least one sitcom and then he
was a he had a lot of experience with
MMA became an MMA announcer while he was
starting his podcast so I sort of feel
like he had a very natural growth in his
career and I'm sure he made some
mistakes but I my mistake was I started
off doing something I didn't want to do
and then I thought I was smarter than I
was and then I made a series of
incredibly bad high-stakes decisions
lost everything and then I repeated the
whole process four or five times so I
wish I had gone from kind of struggles
to success to a little more struggle to
a little more success you know kind of
kind of the natural path of things
instead III III didn't know I had
because of that here's where I could say
I've no regrets I have learned an
enormous amount like I have so much
experience I was able to share it in you
know books and podcasts and so on that I
know I have created some impact and I'm
very proud of that but you know at the
same time I'm kind of I feel like I'm a
little bit scarred on the inside I I
mean I started with absolutely nothing
and thought I made something of myself
but maybe you know it but then I just
started squandering that and I remember
one time this was like that maybe third
or fourth time I went broke I was I had
done the usual bad things I this time I
didn't buy just one big house I bought
two big houses right next to each other
and I had a hammock right in between the
two and I was like lying on this hammock
just just like upset at myself and then
it started raining and it's just almost
like a cliche image but I'm just forever
thinking myself I cannot believe this
has happened to me again and Here I am
I'm just soaking wet I don't want to go
inside and face my kids and and and my
now ex-wife and and admit how much of a
failure I am but at the same time I just
had not nothing to do nowhere to go so
what's the what's the mindset there
because you know there's people who are
in varying gradations of bad bad
situation at the moment like I say it's
not this romantic I I saw the the
butterfly emerge from the chrysalis
and thought that's me I'm this like it
wasn't it doesn't have that sort of that
signature to it what was the to not just
give up
yeah and just just to add quickly to
what you said I think there's kind of
almost a genre of failure porn now in
Silicon Valley like or in
entrepreneurship world where people
basically say oh I failed so now I'm
ready to succeed like its failure as a
badge of honor now I can succeed
everybody will think I'm smarter cuz I
learned from my failures I didn't feel
that way at all I had you know anyway I
already described how bad it was but III
kind of said you know this has happened
to me enough first off I felt like there
was a gun to my head it's not like I was
just gonna give up at this point I had
to do something and so I had to ask
myself well what what was working for me
on the way up and what was not working
for me on the way down
it's not like people sometimes ask me I
want to start a business what's the
right idea or I want to invest something
what's the right stock uh or I need to
find my passion in life well what do I
do and that's sort of like but the last
questions you asked first I had to kind
of build up my inner my inner frame or
my inner presence so that I could have
strength again to succeed and I realized
that's what I had always done on the way
up and I had given up this what I'll
call a daily practice on the way down
and so what how do you so I so I started
very seriously every day focusing and
it's very simple and again it's so
simple it almost sounds like a cliche
but I very simply started focusing every
single day am i 1% better in terms of my
physical health emotional health
creative health and I'll call it
spiritual health for lack of a better
word and physical health means it's very
simple am i eating better moving better
sleeping better doesn't mean I have to
go to a gym and lift weights everyday
doesn't mean I have to be a vegan but
you know my eating am i eating a little
better today than I did yesterday am i
moving around or exercising a little bit
more today than I did yesterday tiny bit
tiny tiny bit am I
sleeping 8 hours a day emotional health
am i pruning the toxic relationships in
my life and focusing on the better
relationships and there's a lot of
reasons for that first off with the
physical health if you get sick you're
not gonna come up with ideas while
you're sick so that's why that's so
important second off with the emotional
health if you're constantly arguing with
a spouse or bad partners or other toxic
people in your life you're not gonna be
creative and have the energy to build a
business or to write a book or to do
exciting things in your life
creative health people don't realize
this but creativity is a muscle and like
any muscle it atrophies within days or
weeks if you don't use it so I just make
sure I'm creative every day specifically
what I try to do is I try to write down
ten ideas a day like oh what are ten
ideas for business I could start what
are ten ideas for our books I could
write and it by the way it doesn't have
to be about me I could say what are ten
ideas Jeff Bezos should do to make
Amazon better
what are 10 ideas Gmail can have to be
better and there it's not intended to
create businesses that I could start
because I'm coming up with 3650 ideas in
a year like you can't you can't act on
more than one or two of those but the
whole idea is again to exercise that
idea muscle what happens when I'm coming
up with 10 ideas my idea number seven
it's like my brain is sweating like it's
if you're if you're if you're doing it
right or you're trying to come up with
the best ideas for the category you list
I'm so I'll keep counting and have I hit
10 yet oh no eight how do I come up with
nine and ten and it's just it should be
really hard eight nine and ten and it
usually is and you know people say Oh
ideas are a dime a dozen execution is
everything what they don't realize is
that execution is just a subset of ideas
you need execution ideas in order to
execute because I know people who are
really bad at executing on a good idea
there's a whole spectrum of bad
execution to good execution so you need
to be creative to have good execution
ideas as well which is why this creative
my creativity muscle is so important to
exercise now spiritual health it doesn't
mean pray doesn't mean meditate
although it could mean those things it
just means a little bit more of a sense
of some things in life you can't control
some things you can't don't be anxious
or fearful or worried about the things
you can't control
focus on the things you can't control
and keep expectation expectations low or
else you're gonna set yourself up for
disappointment
those you're gonna be in a helicopter
flying next door by the way I'm taking
Alec op2 tomorrow so I'm rockin out but
and again I might just focus on these
four things each day and nothing else
like don't don't worry Oh am I gonna be
broke two years from now am I gonna how
am I gonna feed my kids six months from
now just simply get back to that
practice of did I improve myself
physically emotionally creatively
spiritually take because those of you
it's right like today right now those
are the only things you can control
yeah maybe I can send two or three
emails to connections or maybe if I have
a great idea for Amazon and I know
somebody at Amazon I could send an email
to Amazon here's my ten ideas for you
but most of the time you can't do that
you just have to focus on what you can
focus on today by the way
sending idealists to other people when I
really feel the ideas are good can turn
directly into dollars one of the things
that I think that's really interesting
is how we try and break down the
messiness of life right life is this big
chaotic amorphous nebulous ephemeral
blob and breaking it down into these
more manageable chunks it appears to be
something that's quite it's quite a
common tactic mutual friend and mutual
podcast guest of ours Kemal rava Khan
his practice about loving yourself it's
a daily practice it's you know it's only
a small part of your day but it eats
into the rest of your day right is there
is is this a modern problem do you think
the fact that we've got this cast a
messy chaotic life at the moment and
people are really struggling to kind of
make sense of what's going on is this a
practice which has only recently become
useful yes or no I mean life is much
more complex now so if you're a surf in
the
1700s in I don't know the Ukraine or
whatever life wasn't really that
Pleasant and wasn't nobody
you wouldn't like say to yourself while
you're surfing the you know why you're
you know plowing through the fields and
pulling up weeds or whatever surfs dead
you wouldn't be saying yourself I've got
to love myself I got to love myself you
just had to do what you had to do but
now everything's complex like you know
we sort of we don't live in our in the
village were born and we don't we don't
see everyday the family we grew up with
we kind of create our environments that
in itself is complex then let's say you
start a business it's so easy to get
caught up in ah did I maximize revenues
today did I reach out to all the clients
that I cover all the details that I pay
everybody did I motivate everybody did I
work on product at all it I don't know
but if you just focus on these four
things I said you'll end up doing the
right thing like if you--if you're doing
that it's not like you'll suddenly say
okay well I'm I'm done with my day now I
can go to sleep no ok if I'm from being
creative of a healthy um if I'm not
worried about my relationships okay now
just now it's time to get work I can
work on an article I could work out an
email to a client you know but I could
collect I could delegate collecting some
you know invoices that are outstanding
whatever it is whatever it is that we're
worried about life is really complex so
it helps to boil down to simple things
where if you do those simple things you
know you're gonna be okay in the long
run like I have huge faith because now
I've seen it in action for a long long
time I have huge faith that if I do my
version of this daily practice and
everybody's version could be different
if I do my version then things are gonna
be great in the long run I never have to
think about the long run if I'm if I did
what I need to do today so some people
tell me oh they have a to-do list and
I'm like why do you have a to-do list
and then they say oh oh to keep track of
the 50 things I have to I have to do and
I'm like well how are you gonna do 50
things like right now what are you gonna
do right now and and they don't really
know they don't really know how to
answer that question
at any given point during the day like
let's say after this podcast I have some
free time and I've already done my kind
of daily practice of the day I wrote my
10 ideas a day down I worked on my
relationships I took a walk whatever
okay if I have some free time and I and
I'm not yet ready to relax for the day
maybe I will write to a customer or
maybe I will come up with you know start
working on writing another article or or
do something related to business or
whatever like you at any point you know
what is the highest priority thing to do
so I don't need to keep it to do list
because at any given point that I have
free time I'm just gonna do the one
thing that is the highest priority and
then when I finish that I'm gonna do the
next thing and now how do I know what's
the highest priority it's not high
priority I'm not gonna think about it
I'm always thinking about what's the
highest priority and then I'll do it one
of the things I'm thinking about as you
were talking about that the serf from
Ukraine I don't even know what a serf is
I thought you meant a surfer one of the
things that I've got in my head there is
that as we've got more abundance and
life has become a lot more comfortable
and convenient for everybody in the 21st
century I'm thinking about Maslow's
hierarchy of needs right and previously
like if you if you didn't have food or
water or safety or you were maybe gonna
freeze or maybe one of your kids was
gonna get taken away by a mountain lion
tonight that you're probably not
wondering about whether or not your self
actualizing like you're right what you
need to worry about is only a few levels
thick great like you know and Maslow's
hierarchy of needs is interesting
because we've kind of gotten through
that first level which is nobody's
really worried about being thirsty later
today like you could just turn on the
faucet and get a glass even if you're
homeless you can most countries in the
world there's places you could go and
get a meal and water and even find
shelter and in fact you know the big
problem with homeless people is not that
people can't find a home is that many of
the homeless people are mentally ill and
are not being treated correctly
but
that aside you know I think a lot of our
basic needs are taken care of and and
then we fool ourselves into thinking
well I'm only gonna be happy when I have
the car I want or or the private jet I
want or whatever when all that is is
stupid like a few years ago I I did an
experiment but I decided to I was
renting two apartments one upstate New
York where my kids were and one in New
York City where all the opportunities
were and both my leases were up and I
don't like to own a place I like to rent
but I decided you know what I don't even
want to rent anymore so I threw out all
of my belongings in both apartments I
had 40 years worth of belongings that I
you know just in general you accumulate
stuff crap over time yeah and you don't
even realize how much you accumulate so
I I was going on a trip and I said to a
friend of mine I said clean out my
apartments and throw you could do it you
could do this you can either give
anything you can either keep anything
for yourself whatever you want to keep
you can keep for yourself or or give to
charity or throw it out and but what I
said when I come back I want nothing at
all I'm not gonna go back to these
apartments I'm never gonna set foot in
them again I don't want I don't want
anything left in them and and I said to
her it should take you just a day you
know just bring your car it'll take a
day
it took she had to rent a truck like an
18-wheeler and it took her her husband
and all her cousins like an entire week
to clear everything out you don't even
realize how much junk you have and the
and the only time she called me during
the whole week because I told her not to
call me at all and know what time she
called me was she said what about your
college diploma you must have worked so
hard for that like you sure you want me
to throw that out and I'm like yeah burn
that because I got nothing out of that I
mean I'm a wreck
acting woman didn't help me at all and
and so then for two and a half years
after that I lived out of a carry-on bag
and just lived from Airbnb to Airbnb and
I made it a discipline for myself if I
ever bought something new like a new
t-shirt I had to remove a t-shirt from
the carry-on bag
so I just had my computer my phone
couple t-shirts couple pairs of pants
and a button-down shirt and that's it
and so I could read books on you know
the Kindle app on my phone and work on
my computer and I had enough clothes to
change it and I'd stay in Airbnb --zz
where there was laundry and that's I
never had to actually I never had to
actually own anything and that's the
reality whether you have a lot of money
or a little money there's nothing you
actually need to own other than a
carry-on bag now if you live in an
apartment that you rent yes you have to
own the basics you have to have a bed
and sheets and maybe a plate or two and
a table to eat on or not like I've I've
been in situations where I didn't have
those things so you know it's amazing
and then after that I so eventually I
stopped doing that but I still have that
discipline where there's nothing really
I I strive for in terms of material
possessions and I'm not saying like I'm
some sort of Monk I do want to I do like
to have a good amount of money but
mostly because you know I want to make
sure going into my older age eventually
that my health is taken care of and as
healthcare gets more and more expensive
and I want to make sure my kids are
taken care of in case there's an
emergency and you know but but that's it
really
I I don't really have what much more
many more needs than that and I like to
be creative I like to have the money to
so I could wake up every day relaxed and
focused and and being creative now some
would argue better to not have money so
you're hungry to be creative but I'm I'm
pretty hungry to be creative have you
watched much of the minimalist
documentaries any of those sort of
youtubes or documentaries on the
movement no although I know those guys
and they've reached out to me before and
we've communicated but I don't really
consider myself a minimalist because I
guess I don't really know what that is I
mean like again homeless people are
minimalist as well not by choice but
yeah right not by choice but and again I
do like to have money I'm not moving
into like a tiny home you know there's
these tiny homes that are like 200
square feet and you have your entire
home there but uh I just wanted to try
this one experiment
no I think a lot of people labeled it
minimalist and maybe it is but for me it
was just my own experiment for me about
about what what do I really need to live
and I was perfectly happy I could have
lived that lifestyle the rest of my life
except for the fact that you know I
think when you want to get when you want
a date and you want to get married you
know you're your spouse might not like
that lifestyle it's a big buy-in yeah
but one of the things so I watched the
documentary a little while ago for
anyone who hasn't seen it it's pretty
cool by the minimalist and um it made me
feel so bloated so bloated it's like the
same as seeing some like incredibly fit
lean athletic gram or on a documentary
or something and you realize just how
physically inadequate to them you are
and then with that I've got they're just
looking around all these different
possessions all of this stuff that gets
used wet or once every year like you
know I mean yeah like one one trick to
use and I I don't know if it's a Marie
Kondo trick or not but one trick to use
is to basically put everything you own
into into you know one room what you
don't use or storage or whatever and
then only go and retrieve things as you
need or want them and then at the end of
the year throw or at the end of six
months
throw out just simply throw out
everything that you didn't use and you
know I think Marie Kondo is a little
different she's like oh lay out all of
your objects on the floor pick up an
object and put it to your heart and if
you love it you got to keep it I don't
really love any of my objects like that
I what what at the end you know if I
write so I'm a writer at heart I've been
writing every day for 30 years since I
was a kid and if I write something good
that day that I love that and that's and
that's about it you know other than you
know my family kids friends but there's
no object I can think of loving one way
when which I'm not a minimalist is I
like convenience so if I'm working in a
certain location I like to live across
the street
from that location that's convenient
and/or if I'm flying somewhere I don't
like to take three stops to save money I
like to just spend the money on no stops
so so uh convenience is very important
to me I think I think money is good for
buying convenience and and by the way
convenience is related to better health
longer life and and many other things
one of the resources that you cannot buy
any more of his time right and when
you're talking about the the extra cost
whatever it is that you want to say it's
okay how much would you pay for I don't
know like I've been in New York I went
last year and a commute in there takes
days it's measured in days yeah
how long is this commute you're talking
maybe an hour an hour a day there an
hour a day back two hours a day five
days a week you know however long you're
gonna be working in this business for
all right how much would you pay for for
that because at the end of your life
you'd give you fortune for an extra
minute yeah that's right so I think
that's very important now but now all
that might change when there's automated
driving I I think you'll see kind of
these mobile offices driving around so
you can live much further away from your
place of work and stuff because you
could work in your your mobile office
but right now I like to I mean basically
everything I do during the 90 percent of
the things I do during a week happen
within 250 feet of where I'm sitting
right now do you think I'm sort of
envisioning like a flexible workstation
like a library on wheels in an
articulated vehicle with like quite nice
Airy windows do you see us get in that
soon yeah yeah well 10 years man I am
James I'm so ready for that I'm so ready
to take a journey someplace and just be
be able to have do you think they'll
have standing desks I'd love it if they
had standing desks I don't know but I
mean if you think about it like right
now the equivalent is like if you're
taking a train in to work and but then a
train you're kind of you know it's a
little crowded you're sitting next to
somebody you don't really have like a
desk but still I've heard of people
doing remarkable things on their commute
to work by working on the train right in
I've heard about one friend of mine
wrote a page a day of a murderer mystery
and ended up now he's got a three books
in the series one detective and he said
he did one page a day on the train and
then another person wrote the movie
pitch perfect by writing one page today
on the subway and to work and so I've
heard stories like that and but I do
think when when everything is automated
and convenient and quick there'll be
people will think about this in terms of
lifestyle like hey how how can I live
further away from you know the city and
get all the but all the benefits of like
being at work which is what automated
driving should give us hmm what do you
think about people finding meaning as we
get increasing automation and increasing
convenience and stuff like that you know
what we've talked about today is looking
after some of the basics to go back to
Joe Rogan is a good example he thinks
that one of the things that we all
require in life is to overcome adversity
to have some sort of I don't think he
would call it suffering but some kind of
challenge to and incrementally increase
that challenge over time is there a
concern as we automate and make
convenience hire and hire people have to
do less and less for themselves that
there's going to be some everyone's just
gonna be struck with this existential
crisis as you'd like laid in bed getting
McDonald's pumped into you by like by a
drone well that's a great question let
me ask you right now do you have an
existential crisis today not this second
I need to go shopping in a supermarket
later on and it tends to strike me there
I hate shopping in a supermarket but no
wait you're right but but but like you
wake up and you think okay Who am I
gonna have on my podcast you wake up and
think what opportunity what other
opportunities can I explore who can i
Network with who can i connect who can I
help so and yet the scenario you just
described already exists like you say
you have to buy it go to a supermarket
well your supermarket has a website you
could order online and if you trust the
people who do the packaging at the
supermarket you'll get just as
high-quality food as if you had gotten
there yourself and it'll be delivered
right to you I sort of think the weird
thing about entrepreneurship the past
ten years is
there's been this weird lack of
innovation and instead everybody who's
an entrepreneur has been focused on how
do you make how do I make everybody's
life so that they could just sit on a
couch all day long and binge watch Game
of Thrones so for instance I can I can
get a master chef make me a great meal
and somebody will deliver it to me you
know I can use GrubHub or seamless or
doordash or whatever someone will
deliver it right to my home I could then
if I wasn't home by the way I could take
an uber to go home and then I could turn
on Netflix and somebody some great
director and writer spent two hundred
million dollars making the irishman
movie and I could just watch it on my
home I don't have to go to a movie
theater anymore and if you need to go to
the bathroom to have a toilet break you
can continue it on your phone your
mobile device so that you don't have to
stop watching it while you go to the
bathroom by the way which I which I do
that like so so I think I think almost
every company in the past ten years and
I'm exaggerating a little bit you
there's examples otherwise but almost
every company has been designed just to
make it more easier more easy for me to
just sit on my couch all day and binge
watch so yeah and then there's other
companies that have come in in a way to
try and antidote that problem but still
the ethos is the same like peloton is a
perfect example peloton is working to
try and get people to go and do the
workout it's the antidote to the fact
that you're sedentary but bizarrely it's
delivered in a way which is so hyper
convenient as that you don't even need
to leave you you know everyone every
single person in a peloton art has floor
to ceiling infinitely glass kitchens
that overlook a beautiful park somewhere
in a tower block but really put the they
put the bike right in front of the the
view and their kids are eating cereal
right next to them and it's like they're
in a gym and they do all the work cited
you don't even have to go to the gym
anymore and I think we've already hit
that existential moment and we it has it
wasn't an issue really like it's not
like we say oh gosh I could just binge
watch all day or I could watch tick tock
videos all day some days I do watch take
time videos all right
right but but you still at the end of a
day like that you feel like oh that felt
kind of I that felt kind of bad actually
I feel kind of nauseous almost and so
the next day then you get up and you
work and if you don't if you're like
lacking motivation then you know some
people do suffer from that and the key I
always get back to is well okay did you
1% improve physical health emotional
health creative out spiritual health
because if you do that it'll solve a
problem if you're writing down ten ideas
a day you're not gonna just say to
yourself well I was creative for the day
now I can watch tick tock videos for the
rest of the day you're gonna want to do
things you're gonna get excited about
some of your ideas yeah like like like
I'll tell you my idea list for today
okay
have you ever this is a random one it's
not a good idea like most ideas are not
good ideas yeah
so I'm just trying to say that you come
with 10 ideas for the exercise not to
come up with good ideas you'll the good
ideas will take care of themselves but
I've ever played the game cards against
humanity' I bought it for me and my mom
my dad for Christmas yes so so I came
with this idea I'm gonna make a card
game trump trump against humanity and so
you have all the cards are all and then
my 10 ideas were like the 10 rules and
so and so you have all these cards that
are each card is Trump's tweets and then
there's another deck with all of the
possible world situations that could
possibly happen and then everyone's got
to throw the tweet that matches it the
best and then the judge of that round
picks the best Trump tweet that matches
this world crisis and so I wrote down
all the words and they even wrote down
some execution ideas well what would be
my first three steps to get this started
anyone could steal this idea because I
think it's probably a bad idea and you
know and then that was it I was done
with my 10 ideas a day but then it
didn't stop me from working then I
started working on other articles that I
needed to do I made some business
contacts I made some I'm starting a an
email newsletter for some other projects
I'm working on so I just kept kept going
after that
and an alum on this podcast which is
very valuable to me and thank you for
once again for asking me out
thank you for being here one of the
things a quote from Navarre rava count
is that all of our problems at the
moment of problems of abundance not
scarcity and you are you mentioned
earlier on you can't action on three
thousand six hundred and fifty ideas per
year you can maybe do one or two of
those if you got some good resources and
maybe a team with you how do you how do
you choose
you got these three thousand six hundred
and fifty ideas James I'm swimming in
post-it notes here yeah well that's a
great question because they're like most
things the answer is not totally simple
but it's not hard either you're gonna
like let's say let's say I liked this
Trump against humanity' idea okay now I
can now maybe one execution idea is I
can go to Fiverr fi fi ve RR where you
can hire people at very cheap prices
from all over the world to do tasks for
you and I could say to somebody you know
give me a spreadsheet with all of trumps
tweets and then I could go on Fiverr and
or or I could list myself you know come
up with 500 world crisis situations and
then I can find someone who manufactures
cards and I can outsource to them making
the cards okay at any point in this
process if I realize you know what this
is not a very exciting idea you like
your heart will tell you and by the way
now your creative creativity muscle is
active enough to that will tell you
you'll realize halfway through this is
not a good idea like oh I can't figure
out 500 world crisis situations or it's
too expensive to make these cards before
I really know so maybe I'll try a
GoFundMe or something
so so again I but I just gave you three
or four execution ideas that in in total
would take me about 15 minutes to
execute on so I can actually create an
entire version of this game with maybe
15 minutes to an hour's worth of work so
with that would you say that this is one
of the one or two great ideas of the air
that I'm gonna work on
No maybe after that hour nobody wants to
play the game and whatever so that's the
end of that idea I I had another idea
once I and by the way I have ideas all
the time because I'm writing these
things down I had an idea
oh I should buy you know Donald Trump
tweeted that America wanted to buy
Greenland okay and everybody made fun of
it and Denmark which owns Greenland said
well Greenland's not for sale and and so
I came up with my ideas for the day that
day were ten reasons why somebody would
want to buy Greenland and turned out
that we're actually very interesting
reasons not mentioned in Trump's 280
characters there were there was very
interesting reasons to potentially buy
Greenland and very diverse reasons and
so I started a Kickstarter and a
GoFundMe where I explained all the
reasons and I said help me buy Greenland
and so I put this on Kickstarter and
GoFundMe and believe it or not I started
raising money people were donating $50
here $100 there and I had all sorts of
tiers where like if you gave over $100
you could be a Duke in Greenland after I
buy it and and so it was by the way the
whole thing again took me after I'd
finished the idealist the idea of kind
of doing a Kickstarter and a great and a
GoFundMe that took me about a half hour
to implement and come up with all the
tiers and actually launch it and then I
tweeted about it i facebooked about it I
shared the GoFundMe on my email list and
and social media again that took me
three minutes and then and then
Kickstarter and GoFundMe both shut me
down and okay lie to you try and raise
money to buy a nation is that against
what well I was trying to raise a
hundred million dollars and they didn't
think I would succeed so they would get
stuck with the credit card charge back
fees so so I could I would like to say
that it was for political reasons that
they shut me down which makes the story
more interesting but it was really just
a financial decision on their part and
and but so so I did all this the entire
thing took me a day and it was a fun
idea it was a fun experience
I learned something about not on today I
learned something about Greenland but
I'd never done a Kickstarter or go
GoFundMe project before so I learned
something I learned valuable skill and
and did I get anything out of it yeah I
have a story I could tell you so now
that's an entire story about it's a
classic case of experimenting with an
idea by the way if the idea succeeded
what does success mean for that idea
well maybe news reporters would pick up
on this and I would get some renown and
who knows maybe people would have this
discussion about why this was happening
and and it would it would turn into
something exciting I don't know like
there would be some some excitement from
it that would be generated so that was
success but I had no downside I had an
hour of my time and my the upside that I
did get for that hour was I have a great
story which I'll probably include in my
next book which is gonna be all about
you know I'm part of it's gonna be about
how to do experiments in your life to
try to improve your life and I have I
have experiences like that all the time
and experiments like that all the time
because I'm constantly trying ideas but
I give myself a very low threshold to
quit the idea so ok Kickstarter and
GoFundMe cancelled it I don't really
need to I'm not really gonna buy
Greenland so I don't really need to do
anything else and I got a good story out
of it time to move on to the next idea
ideas are abundant which goes along with
ideas are a dime a dozen ideas are
abundant so I know I'm gonna have more
ideas to experiment with maybe even
every single day which is true how do
you allow yourself to have this
optionality whilst still sticking to the
core things that you need to work on in
life because you could potentially
continue to chase shiny objects for a
very very long time
well yes wood I don't know what your
particular opinion is but it's sort of
common held productivity wisdom that you
should have a balance between explore
and exploit right and that the explore
should only be a portion and the exploit
should you be increasingly doubling down
on the things that you find yourself to
be good at do you disagree yes
no I agree with that so so for instance
I'm experimenting with an idea and I'm
like oh this feels good and I'm enjoying
this
then I'll double down on it like let's
say I have an eye and and I know you're
asking also there's like certain things
you have to do like your job your work
you make money and so on but let's say
hypothetically I started writing a
mystery novel and after a page or two
I'm excited and I'm enjoying it and I
don't know if it's gonna be good or bad
or whatever but if I'm enjoying it your
heart is a compass and it will tell you
what you should keep doing so if you're
enjoying something and and it's and
you're passing you don't seem to be
hitting those thresholds at each point
of when you should quit then you just
keep doing it and that's usually how
everyone every business I've ever
started starts is that oh I have an idea
for a business
oh I start implementing it all those
customers interested now I'm enjoying it
maybe I'm gonna make money off of it and
I just keep going you know the podcast I
started a podcast I did one it was fun I
did - it was fun I started get a ver
tyler's I was bringing in money more
people are showing up who want to be on
the podcast I hire people to help me oh
and I really enjoy it I'm learning so
much from it so I just keep doing it one
thing you know you accelerate on the
things you enjoy but now let's say you
let's say you have a nine-to-five job
and let's say you have kids at home and
you know you have the regular classic
workday when do you win where you have
time to do this well first off in a
nine-to-five job and I've had nine to
five jobs everybody's had and everybody
will have the average person and this
studies on this the average person works
about two-and-a-half hours a day at a
nine-to-five job the rest of the time
they're kind of just like you know on
social media or they're taking a lunch
break or a cigarette break or whatever
so you know that's average some people
work more hours some people work less
you know but all the experiments I just
described to you took me an hour at the
most
you're incredibly productive you're that
you're the most productive person in
your workplace if you're working for
five full hours um that's still plenty
of time to experiment on whatever it is
you're experimenting on I'll tell you
what
more story this could have been a
business it is so I had I was at a
dinner and there were two people at the
dinner a friend of mine was at the
dinner and and see in a while he had he
brought his new girlfriend and they were
all they were in their 40s and they were
all cute and cuddly and I said all
things sounds like things are going well
for you guys you know I was just making
conversation and he said yeah we there
smiling yeah we just had the
conversation we decided to go steady and
I thought that's such a weird phrase
right now and and so I asked him like
what does that really mean
and and he said well we're not we
deleted our dating apps from our phones
and so I thought to myself on my
idealist the next day I was thinking of
ideas for apps and I said oh maybe there
should be a going steady app where if
you're gonna be going steady with
somebody you you get the goings you each
get the going steady app on your phone
you now connect with each other on the
going steady app it automatically
deletes all the dating apps from your
phone facebook relationship status yeah
all that stuff and and it it it notifies
the other person if they start
downloading dating apps again no [ __ ]
L so if you start liking booty pictures
if you start randomly following a bunch
of people that are from like your area
from the opposite sex so so see like
these are I I didn't put those ideas
down but those could be ideas or those
could be settings like you could decide
how restrictive you want to be a
Riesling
right here we go we're on we're in ideaa
generation now [ __ ] the podcast James
but boy here here's what I did though is
that then I the next day I wrote my
ideal list was 10 screens I kind of
sketched out 10 screens on this going
steady app and then I uploaded them to
freelancer.com
where I wrote the whole spec of the app
and put up these screens and I said what
what programmers out there can do this
for me in the next two weeks and it's a
reverse auction so programmers from all
over the world Malaysia India
wherever they all were bidding to do it
and I had like a hundred programmers
from around the world bidding like
within a half-hour and I just had one
simple question which is can and both an
iPhone and Android can an app recognize
what apps are also on the phone because
that's what the going steady app would
have to do and the answer is for Android
yes for iPhone No so that means this is
not a good idea I can't do this idea so
the whole thing again an hour's worth of
my time for something that potentially
could have been an amazing business who
knows because it's a very viral sort of
business because it has that network
effect built in so it would have been
probably a good idea and but you
physically can't do it with the iPhone
which is 70% of the US market so boom
that was the end of that experiment and
but I generated a story I gained
knowledge every experiment you gain
knowledge I learned something new about
the iPhone and you know and it took me
essentially zero time even if I worked a
nine-to-five job I got you right I want
to do idea generation because we've
stumbled on something probably the most
important question that we've brought up
so far which is that there is not
acceptable term there's not term that
I'm happy with for what it is when it's
more serious than just sleeping with
somebody and less serious than being in
a relationship there is going steady I
don't think I mean you know that to me
that's like courting that's like your
parents asking you if you're courting
anyone or there's in the UK there's
seeing somebody would be would be the
equivalent of like going steady I just
feel like okay here's here's an idea
here's an idea if you're on e let's say
you're talking to a heterosexual man and
you're trying to figure out if if their
girlfriend is is is it just dating is it
more serious is it is it leading to
marriage is it marriage so what's
somewhere in the middle the good
question is and this comes from I think
the TV show Seinfeld is she a Saturday
girl like on Saturday are you expected
to not make any other
plans other than Caesar well one of the
problems with that is there is another
subcategory within the people that I'm
talking about who are people that have
Sunday boyfriend's and that's a
boyfriend that they only have on a
Sunday CC subvert it you've submitted
the the Saturday girl thing
not that you're supposed to be there on
a Saturday this is a mark of how highly
I hold you in regard it I only want you
on a Sunday this [ __ ] all else happening
let's get popcorn and Netflix but but
when what is that person doing on
Saturday night probably his he ended
probably trying to find a levelled up
Sunday girlfriend right so that's what I
mean so okay the Saturday Girls more
serious than the Sunday boyfriend or the
sunday girlfriend that's only because
they're prioritizing Saturday over
Sunday a lot to be fair to be fair
there's more stuff happening on a
Saturday isn't there there's more
particularly for your time on a Saturday
wait is that the world prioritizes
Friday and Saturday nights as date
nights like if so if if you're going out
seriously with with somebody and she
says on a Saturday night and you just
don't hear from her about Saturday night
and she never communicates that you're
that you're going to think to yourself
well what's and if you think you're
serious you're gonna think yourself well
what's she doing on a Saturday night
because there's nothing else to do if
you're then I mean there's so many
things to do but you'll think me
thinking she must be going out to meet
somebody else
mhm so I'm gonna be doing something okay
so I degeneration time I'm in New York
this weekend I'm not I'm in New York
this weekend and I want to take a girl
out on Saturday night
what is a slightly different eccentric
sort of date idea so by the way that's a
great question because and again that's
worthy of idea generation because you
don't want to just do dinner and a walk
that's like what everyone does you kind
of want to do something interesting and
there's lots there's a spectrum of ways
you can do this so for instance some
basic ideas you know in New York there
are there's a ping-pong club called spin
it's a little bit different for most
people to go and say on a date and play
ping-pong but I have found that to be
a very successful technique because
usually they've never usually most
people have never gone to play ping-pong
on a date and at the ping-pong place
there's dinner there's drinks it's a
whole club there's music and there's
ping-pong and you know New York City
also there's this for whatever you're
interested in there's something to do so
you know you could go to a bar that has
disco dancing you can go to a comedy
show you could go to a haunted house
experience you can go to an escape room
you know so these are just a few ideas
here's one idea I once did we were gonna
meet and figure it out we were gonna
meet at like this yogurt place so I I
went to the yogurt place an hour early
and the girl behind the counter her name
was Leticia and she was from the Bronx
in New York was just African American
and I said okay I'm gonna be back here
in an hour
and I'm and there's gonna be a woman
waiting for me already as soon as I walk
in I want you to say oh my god James
what are you doing here we worked out a
whole script where this girl who was
african-american clearly you know not
related to me we were gonna be first
cousins like and and we had a whole
script and a whole backstory and we
fooled my friend it's a completely thing
he was she she was like no way
this is not true and and this girl
Leticia we I filled her in on my
background enough that it was very
convincing and vice versa
and you know that was a fun way to start
things man you nailed it so I went the
back end of last year I went to Jeff
Wayne's War of the Worlds virtual
reality experience presented by dot in
London have you heard of this no but no
but a VR experience is a great idea man
this is so much more than a VR
experience if you're over in the UK you
have to do it's just got extended to
anyone who's listening and wants an idea
for something to do in London I can't
recommend it more highly so it's a
combination of a our augmented reality
holographic projection real-life actors
with actual effects proper special
effects and the most advanced virtual
reality technology that's around
so you arrive and you're met by this guy
at the front so the whole front of its a
bar that you then it's like a waiting
room and you're not in it and as soon as
you go through into the little corridor
and you're met by an actor and from that
point it's just actors guiding you
through this whole thing and this its
massive walkway they've created and then
you go and watch them when they land the
meet your Lance's flames real-life
flames inside of this room then you've
got to get out there come in and blah
blah and then you go to the next room
okay right you got to put the headset on
now you're walking around and doing all
this stuff and it was like a two-hour 45
minute experience of this the most so
it's centrally stimulating overwhelming
experience I've ever had the only bad
thing I can say about it for a day is
you don't get to know [ __ ] anything
about your date because you're just
completely immersed in this crazy
experience and I was just fully nerding
out as well I was they were saying like
who wants to help patch up this injured
civilian on the side and it's like this
actor who's like Britta gotta pretend
we're now so I'll do it I'll do it like
I just wanted to I wanted to be a part
of it so it made me look really uncool
I don't we didn't I didn't get to learn
anything at all about her but it was
like just such a like a memorable
experience for sure for me at least
right oh look that's an idea on the list
of ideas of like what's an interesting
date night another thing is find
restaurants where there's the restaurant
but then you happen to know there's
another restaurant in the restaurant
behind the kitchen and so you have to
walk through the kitchen together like I
think I know many of those that is that
quite common in New York no but there's
like two or three I know of and it's
always that's on my list of ideas like
if you know if I were to ever you know
I'm married now so I'm not planning on
going on any first dates anymore for the
rest of my life oh wing my this is this
is purely for for me as a young single
very available man with his email
address in a show notes below and you
know if if there's a girl in New York
that thinks I fancy going into the arse
end of a cafe and taken pasta chef so
that I can go other thing then you can
send me the address and we can yeah so
if you're ever in New York I will tell
you like
the places ago and the things to say to
get into the interesting place and those
are always on the list of ideas too but
again it's when when I was in dating
mode which was a while ago I used the
creativity muscle to come up with these
ideas
[Music]